alright this is the basic of the six
steps so I'm going to explain the most
fundamental move in breakdancing
footwork here's how it starts you are in
a push-up position
body straight feet slightly apart where
you're going to do is bring this right
leg into slightly almost like you're
doing a half a mountain climber then
you're gonna step out this is that about
two o'clock
notice my kids are underneath my
shoulders then you come in behind this
bent like you want this foot to be
underneath your hips underneath your
right butt cheek in this case then this
leg is gonna come out so like that and
you're gonna flip it to the other hand
right notice in this position I can sit
comfortably this is very important
so when your legs are behind you if you
were to draw a line horizontally when
your legs are behind this horizontal
line you want them to be straight out
this is a general principle you don't
want your hips to be above your
shoulders okay and when your legs are in
the front you want your at least one leg
to be underneath your hip so you're
moving okay so then we come through here
notice it's exactly the opposite of what
we did on the other side then you're
gonna kick out straight and then come
back to this position just plank
position position with your legs across
so now in faster speed I'll show you
what that looks like okay
all right so once again we're here
common mistakes you're going to be have
your hips way up yours looks ridiculous
you also don't want to end out here this
is another common mistake also looks
ridiculous have been a lot of strain on
your shoulders so looks like this slight
step up leg out here on the heel or on
the side of the foot or the heel in
right foot under right butt cheek then
what we're gonna do is switch to the
right hand as I bring this leg
underneath boom across out and then here
we go okay so that's the six step few
other notes
notice that I'm on the palm of my hands
like this it's because I lack
genetically the flexibility in the
fingers if you can take your fingers and
bend them back so that there are 90
degrees of this backcourt of your hand
it will help you to be up on those on
the pads of the hand be careful with
your thumbs you can break your thumbs
but that extra three to four inches will
make you look better so elevate your
shoulder knowledge of your hips okay so
a few embellishments that you can add
the basic six step so we're here come
here so you can also jump so instead of
bringing this up and then through you
can jump like this okay so that's
slightly faster version or here jump
straight to this this point where you
have the right foot under the butt cheek
here here
okay and then if you speed this up you
end up incorporating a kick through just
like you would if you're doing this type
of move and the way it translates it
looks like this okay okay it's a much
faster version be careful your wrists
with the basic six step a few things you
can do so put here boom when you get to
this position you can move down either
side which is a lot of fun so I can
throw my weight this way and then walk
with very small steps of my feet place
okay
you got other things you can do if you
extend one leg here you're just going to
pivot on this leg
use this hand for a flourish come over
like that and then go back into the six
step so we mean by that is okay back
into normal
all right other things you can do put
your knees down another very easy
embellishment so my position jump in in
boom boom now I'm just going to bring
instead of come in here I'm gonna put my
left knee down and then follow my right
knee you'll see what this looks like now
I'll be right back in the sixth step
okay so there's some basics what I want
to show you now it's how you get into
the system so this is going to be the
entrance